businesses continue to clean up damage
from the weekend demonstrations Kristen
Drummond is live at a gas station at
Koval and Tropicana where a store there
was looted as we brought you last night
at 11:00 Kristin yes Brian we are right
across the street from the rubble store
as you can see behind me plywood now
does cover a window metro police tell us
that several people from the strip
protest came here they set trash on fire
got into a fight and then staff tell us
today that they were looted they did not
tell us how much were taken or what was
taken however this was not the only
place in the valley damaged last night a
few stores at the Las Vegas North
Premium Outlets were broken into some
businesses were closed for the day while
others decided to board up the windows
as a precaution now crosstown Metro
sources say a group of people through
several Malte cocktails at the front
windows of a colles buy Charleston and
Nellis damage appears minimal and
customers were still able to shop there
today but the destruction is frustrating
to those who want to keep the community
safe and the demonstrations to remain
peaceful I kind of wonder sometimes is
it all you know these so-called
protesters that aren't even a part of
the solution you know it's the question
of are they trying to be a part of a
solution or a part of the problem
cleanup is still happening in downtown
Las Vegas city maintenance crews and
volunteers continue removing graffiti
after demonstrators tag businesses and
property during Saturday's protests
metro police did make several arrests
yesterday as well as at the outlet mall
reporting live Kristin Drummond 8 News
now